huh um hey guys zariene clean shaven
moustache is gone for the interim I'm
supposed to be meeting Jerry here
because we were going to record a dank
ass subs episode talking all about
marble hornets you know the the shoe
movie always watching is out on VOD
we're going to review that probably bad
the Slender Man mythos a little bit but
i'm not seeing re anywhere really just
found his phone so that's gotta count
for something right um so you you can
stand by it we'll get right back to you
as we figure out these tech old ibid
mustache
call these um enjoy
yeah yeah I'm doing that well I'm all
right how are you doing all right long
week it's been it's been a helluva leads
but a hell of a kind of big leagues this
I don't reckon that's never written on
them yeah moving on up that's the only
part of Jefferson okay um I'm feeling
like very like aslan on the slab right
now okay do it like you remember one in
I mean have you have you have you
sacrificed yourself for the betterment
of a whole realm I got shaved oh that's
right yeah you had a shame I was up for
those of you who aren't here in the
studio with us Aaron's beard is gone now
his mustache I'm sorry mustache is gone
yeah you're a mustachioed chap it's like
I was I was up in California's beautiful
and low Valley we're in a you know being
in a feature flim and for the purposes
of it I had to ditch my trademark you
had to part with here that was your
cookie duster yeah mmm does your does
your upper lip feel cold all the time no
it just yeah I don't know what it is but
like I remember in past experiences
works like I would have a mustache for a
while now would shave for whatever
reason it's like you feel weird and kind
of rubbery but yeah but not this time
around this time around i guess i was i
was a little bit more mentally prepared
because i knew this was coming two ways
in advance you had time to get
acquainted with the idea yeah and
depending and depending on how how
things pan out i may have another film
project where
where I I might have to ditch the
mustache again but in its stead grow
some big like what are described in the
script as porkchop sideburns yeah so
you're gonna be like a Civil War general
no I'm if it all depends on whether or
not I'll and this this gig but it's it's
like a kind of a post college-age
burnout guy right the kind of dude that
would have porkchop sideburns okay yeah
so nice that is where I'm at in my life
facial hair adventures so I hope it pans
out I would love to see you with some
pork chops up would you really yeah oh
boy I would yeah I'm always for pork
chops a ground just porkchop sideburns
and applesauce goatees yeah just a hold
just a whole five course dinners apple
bottom jean man booze with the fur with
the fur the whole club looking at her
because how did that grow grow those
porkchop sideburns it's like man what's
your secret i couldn't even grow like a
beard problem how does this lady have
these like majestic righteous a shy side
versus was your dad a Civil War general
probably yeah yeah yeah cornstarch
Jackson this surge a cornhole Jackson
kornel is an actual game cornholes game
they playing like Midwest really yeah or
you just get these bean bags and thrown
through a whole piece of wood so it's
basically so it's like the name for just
like that game where you throw being
back to prove his wood yeah it's like I
don't know if it has a name in
California boy uncle corn because no
one's gonna put that my hands of
children to do as they please hey kids
you all play gave a cornhole t said corn
yeah welcome to deck at Stubb's 2014 I'm
I'm still Aaron I'm still Jerry yeah we
haven't change the fabric of space-time
as a James yeah we're so we're still who
we are it is mess you know we haven't
changed me changed
changed man you sold out yeah we got
some big-time sponsorships you're making
you're making paper that's not sure what
I make a paper but we do a big-time
sponsors yeah we do you just got our
first sponsorship limon do you have the
copy for the liminal minded there's so
much [ __ ] in here all these sponsorships
nice all these here I got it we gotta
give a shout out to all over our
corporate sponsors were given us the
sick kickbacks sick ass kickbacks
allowing us to record in our garage yeah
in in Jane gasps garage studios Thank
ask for Raj stew on Garageband on
Garageband yeah we're doing these right
now yeah who knows though maybe maybe
one of our fabulous sponsors here will
help us move on up to the east side Lisa
yeah east side of burbank East Berlin I
think he was the east side of birthing
not sure what side of Burbank is this
this is east magnolia yeah the side of
burbank will just be bordering on
glendale on that one we go to the
americana at brand I do like the America
a la Americana is a nice place have you
gotten didn't summit that dim sum place
soon no I forget the name of it fits
really good we read The Grove the other
day the grove tonight groans great
shouts out to the glendale pasadena area
for having really cool malls yes shout
out to just massive hubs of corporate
spending yeah consumer ship love it hell
yeah it's the best tube f'd yeah so our
first our first major sponsor I
shouldn't yeah I should meet the
notifications I was noticing last time
like Ivan no isn't a multiple times yes
thing or it's like I'll think I'm
getting texts just because Texas showing
up on the audio yeah yeah so our first
corporate sponsor first corporate
sponsor here we go who wrote this what
does this say just can't go like that's
just what we got that's what the email
said I just print up e okay yeah let's
just wrong Tara ween spooky days I um
in spooky days uh it's a s it's like a
Halloween on type event yeah when
they've got good they've got some like
flash art or something like like clipart
in here yeah a spider and some pumpkins
yeah text beneath uh this open every
days except thursdays through sundays
it's spelled since new days you j it's
nothing but i'm guessing it's some weird
this weird time for a haunted attraction
to not to be open yes all I guess if you
want to avoid the competition just open
up on all the other day yeah I'm a
weekday yeah um okay towie's spooky days
uh it says here much frightening much
frightening and new speio key things
supposed to be spooky spooky maze is a
spider and there's a clip art of is the
clip art spider yeah so i guess the new
maze is spiders theme door yeah i got a
spider inspired cool yeah yeah Thank You
Terrance thank you so much too Terrance
poopy days and all the good things you
do to RT Weems it's misspelled here to
us oh weird HRT Weeden soup cadets where
where pump Kip them now have faced and
there's a picture of I guess it's a
jacket it's the pumpkin that someone
drew a face on like it's a
jack-o'-lantern um this is [ __ ] wild
all right thank you for sponsorship
chair whisper today thank you so much
darling spooky did hopefully they will
get spell check and sponsor us again yes
I hey what what a great sponsor who
sponsor one of our first re inaugural
episodes about a horror movie that's
right about some so what a horror movie
and some liked extraneous or webisodes
yeah you know what's uh we want to do
the honors since you brought this to me
Liz flashback to 2010 yeah also 2010
this one this happened was it I
idea one in heaven but it sounds like
late 2010 yeah something way less some
point back in the day I happened upon an
interesting web series that caught many
people's eyes except the eyes of any of
our friends yeah cuz it was just the it
was just the two of us reserves you
showed me and I was like oh this is so
cool and then we showed our friends one
night before we before we showed
everybody before we went to repo yeah
and no one was down no one was into it
no one was into it with us but we
persevered yeah we kept tuning in
clandestine Lee yeah that's an N Victor
um and that that web series was of
course Marble Hornets which is probably
one of the most famous if you could call
that one of those famous projects out
there focusing on the Slenderman yeah
son the Slender Man myth the Slender Man
you know narrative kind of started on to
something awful forums years and years
ago like back in 2009 i think it was six
years ago yeah Slenderman Slenderman
Slenderman is probably like an expert on
dinosaur yeah every every six races
drills is an expert on that understands
the [ __ ] out of paleontology so um so
it's like not long after slender miss
are taking off on something awful forms
a bunch of like intrepid young lads word
film students in Alabama just start
making these disruptors Marble Hornets I
just really imagine them like like in
20,000 Leagues Under the Sea you're so
good just some intrepid young lands with
a with a thirst for adventure just in
this in this submarine and instead like
you know scouring the ocean and finding
the ruins of Atlantis or or more out on
safari either an island you know thurs
do this giant submarine under the ocean
depths recording a web series about
Slenderman yeah well MarbleHornets up by
troy wagner alex delarge and tim
something Alan timothy allen of home
improvement thing yeah
Tim the slender man Taylor I don't think
so slender and I want to take shows and
reboot them the same except every now
and again the slender man shows up [ __ ]
everything just like got married with
children there's just a slender man in
the background yeah yeah and then like
for the rest of that episode everything
is really dark and weird and then the
next set the next episode just resets
you know just like you do no one even
know mrs. name is just in the background
kind of making things a stir yeah we're
owing tentacle arm God so um so now
we're talking about always watching a
marble hornets story which is the
feature film need to length the feature
the major studio motion picture
adaptation of of marble hornets which
concluded I think about a year ago now
now which studio what the money I have
no idea but the production company it
was picked up by the same guys who did
the other guys uh mosaic mosaic mosaic
who initially from them yeah who did the
other guys and bad teacher I was like
their major name movies that they put
out um so comedy moving into low budget
or wanna and directed by and I misspoke
earlier of the webseries marble horns
was pretty not by an Alex delage but a
Joseph delage alex is his evil twin
brother alex is the character he plays
okay yeah well it's an understandable
mistake yeah Troy Wagner Joseph collage
and Tim's son Tim is the only guy whose
name and character name are the same
okay yes all right yes so yeah it had a
tiny tiny itty-bitty theatrical release
and for the most part it's now a VOD
title on all the major outlets amazon
itunes and the like hmm um and those
just gonna 30 if I lose all right yeah i
mean it's it's you know it's a was like
a mellow kinda cool yeah it was a it was
humble but but you know it had some
charm to it yeah well i mean this is a
you know that the Slenderman thing has
gotten so big big lately and I was like
he's video games and there you know
there are other slender in movies i
think now they're coming out with yeah
there was that there was that movie the
tow man that was like kind of but not
sort of related to that yeah thing came
out or at least that's how it was always
pitched to me like it's kind of related
but not so like yeah it's it's a lot of
stuff now based on that something awful
posting but yeah but this was yeah this
was my first sort of return to Marble
Hornets at all in a while you know it's
a I mean the marble hornets series want
to finally conclude I want say not even
a year ago now is hadley 90-plus
episodes including all like the side
stuff with the the multiple YouTube
accounts see that stuff I wish could
have been incorporated into this movie
somehow because like that was always my
favorite stuff yeah the to the art stuff
yeah like all those weird creepy
dissonant you know yeah little art video
south house just like [ __ ] Dumbledore
our videos we're always we're always a
treat you know and and and gave some
really cool contrast but yeah because I
was like what was interesting about and
kind of intelligent about Marvel horses
Webster's is that you saw the initial
pitch is a guy has a best friend who's a
film student who's making this this
student film and that the suit float was
called Marble Hornets and it has every
trapping of every like cliche bad
student film thing that you can imagine
like stilted non-professional acting
like stolen shots and just like suburban
locales and the storyline is about you
know 20 something's coming back to their
hometown and everything's chain that
things
name and it it's a great study in just
like purposefully bad filmmaking yeah
there's one bit where you see a guy in a
car practicing and running lines for a
phone call to camera testing is just
like saying you know it's just it sounds
different you want ah so I used to miss
it so much when I was in college or lose
episode yeah and it was just so charming
and hilarious it was just like you had
to laugh at us and it was on purpose you
just had to laugh at how I know how
purposefully bad and how authentically
bad this is bit felt and that became
terrified because as this guy's running
this goofy-ass monologue about like
maybe you have just just changed too
much maybe I've changed too much maybe
you have and then he leaves back there's
a unnaturally tall man with no face
standing Stockstill in a doorway outside
of a window oh man well that's it see
like I love wallpaper like that I love I
love those little self-conscious things
with people put in the sort of more
normal side of these little worlds
because that yeah that I that episode
tickle me to death and then frightened
that's great yeah under that's cool
because you know like his Popular's
found footage now is you know that was
like that was like their their approach
was like authentic and sort of lo-fi
enough that even though you know it's
fiction it still sort of has a
believability about it yeah you know and
it's I was always part of the charm of
marble hornets okay yeah and it's so you
know as the the main character of the
series uh Jay played by Troy Wagner well
as he's pouring the storyline is you
know there's his buddy outs crailey play
by Joseph delage and yeah Troy is porn
overall the old mini DV tapes of this
film project called Marble Hornets that
he abandoned and started like acting
really weird over her and you know Troy
starts picking up the tapes thinking
like well I mean it's a shame that all
this work is going to go two ways me I'm
just going to check it out and see if
there's I think that can be salvaged in
and as he goes on you start seeing
videos of al
acting erratically he started to film
himself at all times trying to draw a
weird [ __ ] and then he seems to be
hunted by this by the the marble hornets
version of the Slender Man which is
called the operator guy the skinny guys
can get skinny skinny fella kitty fun
he's just some kind of wise guy uh yeah
give me I think I'd remember as i was
perusing like the hundreds of pages of
the original forum thread that gave her
to the Slenderman someone made like a
found audio thing where it was like a
southern dude getting getting
interviewed in it was like really
brilliantly creepy because there's a
southern dude that just like so skinny
[ __ ] mm-hmm and it just it was it
sounded like it was one of the things
were sounded kind of rustic and and down
homie in like an effectively creepy way
yeah and that's kind of like what made
the original marble hornets web series
so effective cuz it felt like these are
just kids who are way out of their
league with this [ __ ] yeah what did they
should do you know where they're
friendly the firm alibi oh that's right
you said that yeah Wow so it's like
everything is just shot around like
small town Alabama that is where the
slimy mouse well they always everything
takes place in a big city but really so
spooky shits go now it's gonna be an
Alabama yeah at least they're spooky
supernatural [ __ ] goes down cuz you
gotta have somewhere that has like
enough open space with enough trees
because it's like you can't as creepy as
like the lancaster palmdale area is
where I have been it's too flat into too
sparse you can't really hide a
seven-foot tall tentacle man in there
you try you try someone on crank would
find him yeah that's what I wish that
that's one thing I wish could have been
incorporated into this film with you
know cuz they at least got a little
money cuz I was like the pictures where
he selects sort of sprouting arms yeah
or you know just has sort of a black
hole mouth you know it's just little
things like that like i always
appreciate those more love crafty
elements yeah what
he's like his proportions are weird his
limbs or too long and I mean that's
something that is um kind of Lin I've
looked a bit like the Slender Man fan
pages and wiki's importantly there's
like there's like separate factions of
people who are like basically the Pure's
are like that Slenderman has gotten way
too off the mark you know the guy Erik
Knudsen or Victor surge the guy who
really first created this under man and
that something awful thread you know he
set it up right where he was really
creepy and he was like shape-shifting
and he was sprouting new limbs and he
looked just so wrong news never quite
the same and yet that's what made
Thunderman so creepy and they're saying
thing and people who are the sir just as
we've called surges they're like eating
like Victor surge or Erik Knudsen had to
add the add a better version of the
slender man in his pocket whereas
everyone now is more emulating Marble
Hornets where you know this under man
doesn't movie he doesn't really move he
doesn't really shape-shift keeps just
kind of Darren he more like teleports
around yeah it's not so much and just
stands in the background being creepy
yeah and the thing that makes the the
marble horns version that the Slender
Man or the operator what makes him
scarier isn't that he's anything it's
that he's everywhere yeah to me yeah
when I close my eyes it's you I see I'm
sorry it's all right then yeah okay
there's a really romantic moment we have
just then I wasn't expecting that my
heart's all aflutter why do birds
suddenly appear everytime the Slender
Man appears they want to get the [ __ ]
out of there but um and it's weird
because like you kind of see the the
evolution of this mythology and the way
this this being in this entity is kind
of represented going from Slenderman
where he shape-shift e on the internet
to slender man where he's just kind of
like teleporting kind of quantum and
causes crazy disturbances and in camera
equipment in Marble Hornets to now
in always watching where it's almost
like it's and it's crazy because like it
sounds like almost watching seems to do
less with the operator than the
webseries did yeah that was that was a
little bit flooding to me especially
because they got tug Jones yeah like I
thought they're gonna take advantage I
mean I think it's cool that Doug Jones
is there yeah that's awesome but he
almost seems kind of underutilized yeah
like it's cool just because you know
about it but if you didn't know you
wouldn't know yeah and it's yeah like I
that that's that's one of those things
is like I like the movie but in the
website i feel like they did a lot more
scary things or or clever things with
the slender man where is like in always
watching occasionally they'll put him
they'll hide him somewhere yeah but play
the word the where's waldo game of like
wearing the frame is the operators but
hiding out but beyond you know like the
suspense the sort of mild suspense built
by like you know artifacting and you
know camera disturbances you know they
didn't do a ton with just the potential
of that character or that entity anyway
yeah they're like character i guess and
and they didn't I guess didn't use Doug
Jones to his fullest potential the thing
about Doug Jones is like he is a
contortionist he can move his body in
weird crazy ways but then you have him
as the operator in the movie and all in
you know the most he does is just kind
of stand still he doesn't seem to really
move a whole lot he doesn't even give
anybody number nine yeah I mean or give
me back my gun mm-hmm hashtag white
shapes yeah dis do all right yeah no no
operator I get hello opera lor it yeah
Doug dress is the operator it's like he
seems to have been hired for his ability
to wear a lot of makeup on his face that
would wall space not there well that was
a troublesome thing to me also because
like it seemed like they cg his face out
yeah it didn't even seem like makeup
yeah what didn't which like I don't know
I feel like this that would is a little
dismayed me Joe Jones was doing
something really really cool on
set that was like helping everyone
else's performance with his space yeah
and that was what they hired him for and
then they digitally removed his face I
was like okay we had your face on set
that you could impact everyone else's
performance when you were around but in
post we're gonna remove your face so
that you look like the canonical version
of the operator he was actually just
making the troll face on there just like
problem everyone just coming in with
that big-ass grid i can haz children
that's the other thing is I mean think
like because the message board version
you know I was like there's that whole
thing about he takes children he takes
children and he makes people disappear
and like marble hornets I guess kind of
even though they're not children they're
still a young people sighs you're kind
of bought that they would be affected by
this but yeah the movies about adult
yeah like so it kind of further steps
toward normalcy in that regard it's also
the thing about about the Slender Man is
like the belief that he kind of takes
you somewhere yeah or you know he does
weird stuff to you it's like it seems
like the most it seems like the most
this version of the operator does is
just kind of like make you mad scared
make you mad paranoid and you know kind
of narcissistic yeah he always recording
yourself yeah I mean like the the
message for version there the surge
version of the Slender Man he abducted
children like fire started mysteriously
in connection to him you know mass you
know mass deaths of children people like
kind of enthralled in some way and doing
here stuff in mass so disappearances in
the woods almost like a almost like a
Mothman yeah he is kind of like what
there's a lot and just sort of like the
the weird bad only nice stuff of the
victor surge version of the slender net
that kind of harkens back to the mock
man just this dark foreboding entity
that that swoops you up somehow and kind
of you know portends bad news yeah one
for always watching I feel like because
his as much as we are complaining like I
did like the movie and I feel like other
22 it did there
things that were kind of intelligent and
charming but the thing is it's like what
was weird to me is like the things that
were the most interesting about always
watching to me were the characters that
were being hunted by the operator and
their relationship to each other and not
so much really anything to do with the
operator Saul's like the operators like
the least interesting thing and always
watching ironically well yeah it's like
it the horror stuff kind of veers more
toward you know just the mainstream but
like all the other things like it does
have a lot of charisma like the actors
they got for the most part are really
natural yeah and you can just side
characters like you know the first like
when you start seeing like we start
entering the world of you know and so
it's like there's a connection to Marble
horns that you know the web series was
about someone pouring over the old
footage in the history of someone else
who had been hunted by the operator so
this movie has a tude you have a news
crew where's the can of man was it
that's right now yeah there's crew of a
camera man named Milo um uh I don't know
what his exact title is but he's used
kinda like a produce a young hip like
Ivy League you grinning at me oh he's
late [ __ ] boy he's my boy Oh bad this is
our first call back I don't know oh [ __ ]
look at I past episodes Milo Milo the
cameraman Charlie the producer who's
classic [ __ ] boy and and there reporter
um oh my god what was your hair saturday
it's so crazy that she's such an
important character but we can't
remember her name hey man names aren't
important it's it's what you are under
new underneath then what you do that
defines yeah i think it's sera sera the
reporter who has a percocet issue yeah
she kind of like I'd run thrown yeah
she's got a drug problem so this is
these three these three people that can
thrust together in this this news team
that are
and a desert confirmed for Sarah hell
yeah um and they're they're on the hunt
or they're on the trail of a family that
got torn asunder by an operator haunting
by an operation by an offer operation
you actually touch him there's just a
buzzing that's all that happens that's
the worst that happens don't be such a
letter yeah the haunting me all this
time on his face turns red instead of
flesh colored it's just his nose like
that oh where he has no nose of red
light buzz yeah red light buzzes at you
so um so it's like what you know it's
more interesting to me the it's more
interesting to me the these three
characters in their relationship to each
other and it's like everything having to
do with the operator entering their
lives and hot again squeaking them
almost feels kind of secondary well yeah
I mean it's weird because I was watching
this movie there were a number of scenes
that would begin Ravi like oh here we go
like we're shoehorning a romancer we're
shoot forming a drug problem and it
doesn't really seem natural to be
filming some of this stuff but then like
scenes would start to plan I feel like
this is a really good scene yeah like
they're really natural together and I
believe like you know that's really hard
to do in any found footage movies so
it's like like there when they first
start finding the the remnants of the
family that that disappeared from the
from there operator haunting it's like
the guy that the repo guy that takes
them through the house here he's so now
that guy was great I so really feels
like just like a blue collar Apple
balloon I almost wonder and you know
anything's possible I almost wonder if
like that guy actually does that or
something has done some just kind of
municipal work and also just happens to
be an actor on the side yeah because he
was like like he was shockingly natural
yeah he just felt like a real dude going
about his day and his lines like it just
it it didn't feel like it was written
for him it it's a seemed at least the
way he was you know speaking it seemed
like he just really knew what he was
doing so either great research or you
know yeah or just a real dude because
yeah there was
and the one but the one bid where
there's like a bad actor it's a
subversion it's a small town cop that's
like playing too much like if you ask me
yeah fella wasn't playing with a full
deck and then you realize oh my god this
dude is totally playing for the camera
because he's a small-town cop that knows
he's gonna be on team because he wants
yeah he wants to take a register bag the
he was in a movie today who's on TV
today yeah and it's like the one time
you see like the found footage at is
it's almost like the movie is kind of
like running a victory lap is like hey
jokes you think that the sprout footage
movie is going to be like cheesy and
unrealistic well joke's on you yeah
everything is with you well that's it
that's the thing to make my authenticity
that's what I like I think one thing
that does sort of lend itself from the
web series and into this movie is like
the age-old conundrum of all found
footage is like it's so hard to justify
why you're still filming thank you and
the whole thing with marble hornets is
like you know you become obsessive and
you start filming yourself all the time
like yes that's built into their Methos
yeah and that's a really handy thing
because at least partway through this
movie when that starts to take hold
everything makes a lot more sense and
the webseries you had the justification
of one this is a guy pouring through old
footage of a friend of his hey and then
be it move morphs into now I'm trying to
find where he's gone i'm using his old
footage as a clue to see where he went
and then it's i'm filming this because
you know it's kind of like an
alternative reality game works like I'm
filming this because I'm at least aware
of the YouTube audience in some fashion
and if anyone has any info they'll give
it to me over the Internet yeah exactly
so it's like there's that Deb and should
I go missing there's record of my yeah
of my journey so there's that play with
the fourth wall that doesn't it's not
quite the same when you're working with
the format of a feature movie yeah yeah
and I mean you know the the first half
of this movie you know it still doesn't
subvert that for me there were times
where I was still like I don't know why
you're filming this but it's a good
senior pleasure so like it always
managed to stay on that side of a good
nature which was
which is nice you know it's like and
keeping him with like the whole thing of
I don't know wider foamed I've seen it
gets in with these state like he gets in
and out of scenes really fast it does it
is a cut lean expedient little movie and
it does do later on it does sort of do a
nice little at least an attempted
justification just when it when it
allows Milo to kind of be creepy yeah
when it's like you've been filming me
all this time like that yeah kind of
creepy like it acknowledges that and
then it's like it makes the whole
constant filming be a part of Milo's
character yeah so so the first thing you
see in the movie we open on Milo's to
just about no um so there's a there's
like an opening sting of someone that's
gotten become enthralled by the operator
and there's like you know a hidden you
know there's some there's like an
opening sting of footage of someone
that's like going nuts because they're
enthralled by the operator and then we
cut to Milo at a New Jersey party where
he first meet Sarah who's the new
reporter um he's filming the party
because you know that's like what he
does you know and it's less Cloverfield
you because Cloverfield no it's like you
know you said a milos kind of like this
the schlub who can't really interact
with the party but so it's like his one
way of interacting with the party is
like on the other side of this camera
yeah oh cuz you know it a party if I all
to do the camera like you know you you
give yourself a role and the people will
let you pass through room stubby hockey
yeah and then he goes into the bathroom
to find Sarah Sarah is you know I did
meet oh you're the new reporter Oh on
the camera guy who got yada this is my
drug addict this is my drug addiction
I'm already high although she's giving
up drinking yeah which is something well
I think she she started when she I think
when you started going to darken ah
they're like yeah let's get rid of all
the vices anyone in one go yeah so it's
like she sounds like she's in the in the
bathroom like scrounging for four pills
Milo films are
the applique have a little awkward
interaction Sarah's high the count
dancer expense New Year's Eve Sarah uh
you know goes in for the New Year's Eve
kiss my and then we see footage after
that words like Milo is like miles off
basically stalking Sarah and he doesn't
seem like he doesn't seem aggressive
about it but so pretty creepy yeah it's
he's like watching like filling her in
the parking lot of like a growth yeah
she's getting groceries and he's just
like you know watching her and then you
see her going into a meeting hall
ostensibly for a Narconon meeting and
it's like you can kind of see like all
right so he got a crush on her in the
midst of the crush on her he's also
started developing the Savior complex
for her why do you know make sure that
she kicks her habit hmm and then he gets
really threatened when Charlie Charlie
what like [ __ ] boy classique comes in
Charlie who and now there's that one
scene where he got his shirt off and he
is flexing his abs yeah so harsh like
yeah yeah he has a shirt off twice I
know but he flexes hard the second time
when they're in that hotel room those oh
yeah was he does the pose and everything
what turns around like yeah with his v
out yeah like what put my shirt so he's
like he is a classic [ __ ] boy he's got
the blond hair he's got like the blondes
like scruff GQ like like you know
designer stubble beard which looks kind
of weird with blonde hair yeah um and
he's like again these very authentic
Kings very rational he's very not
rational but natural you know he feels
like a very real oh yeah he's
supernatural I mean and even just just
in the little nuances in his performance
you know like they're they're just
little tick just the way you know you
throw in like incidental lines in the
sphere and stuff like that i really like
you really liked what he did like yeah
their lives works like on the phone
where he's just like he's you get some
tip from a contact of his knee just like
i'll thank you you are a handsome man
and just like doing that kind of bro ii
like
fo homoeroticism thing and I'm like I'm
seem like you know big level movies
where people can't cell phone calls as
well as that guy does yeah so GJ on the
phone bread well done gene shapes wicked
sick calls grow way so it's like it's
like that's the most interesting stuff
in the movie it's not the the seven-foot
tall faceless guy haunting everybody
it's this love triangle because Charlie
and Sarah end up end up hooking up
around the time that Milo starts getting
like stopped by the operator and it's
like it's it's it's crazy to me that the
most interesting stuff in this horror
movie is actually the people and the
horse up almost is taking the backseat
well also to like that's the kind of
stuff that is sort of shoehorned into a
lot of movies like I we gotta put some
romance right we gotta give us steaks
beyond the situation or you know they
got to be doing this thing and I think
and usually that stuff is altogether
fine at best or are you know sometimes
it works but a lot of the times it you
know it's kind of bland and this movie
is like the best most believable stuff
yeah so it's almost like I guess I guess
it's a good problem to have yeah where
I'm more wrapped up in your characters
than your monster well because then you
can you know yeah then it you at least
leave with a sense of goodwill it's like
well at least they told the story these
characters and like there are certain
ways things end up that that are almost
all right typical it's like you know
there aren't neat resolutions yeah and
you know mile is pretty much left to be
creepy at our last yeah like well
meaningly creepy at our last note for
him yeah it's um yeah are talking about
the at the very end of the movie well
yeah it's like they they never really
resolve yeah there's also his kind of
stalking of her yeah it's almost like at
the end of the movie his stalking of her
kind of becomes the it's almost like so
at the very end the movie Milo becomes
what they realizes as they're
investigating the family that was
haunted by the operator before
and they find out that you know as soon
as the dad died so it's like the dad
becomes of this family is the one that's
an obsessed with this slender man or the
operator he's on that's filming all the
time and he starts getting in he ends up
becoming enthralled by the operator and
one day he's kind of in a transcendental
killing or so he thinks he thinks he
kills his wife and daughter no his wife
survives yeah and his wife ends up
having to kill him and as soon as he's
dead the operator goes away ok so I'm
remembering these these are the little
moments I'm I could back up he's yeah
there's that whole strangling scene yeah
and then the house burned yeah yeah um
and it's like what's and another thing
is there in the the web series of marble
horns there's the operator symbol which
was you know this sketchy circle with an
X drawn through it and that sort of you
know in the Webster's is never quite
explained what the symbol does is award
him away is it like a sign that he's
been there is it is it like a beacon for
him or whatever in in the in the movie
it's very much in I've been here he
marks people that he's now in these LA
was yeah spooky was here w uz so it's
like when you and then there's our
specific part of the body where the
where the UM where the operator symbol
shows up so it's like you know Milo gets
it first and the dad gets a person looks
like on the on the side of the neck like
on the on the trap um and then the
daughter of the family and Charlie get
it second and it's like lower abdomen
hain't got dem I have yeah and then it's
so it's almost like the movie shoehorns
a reason to show off the dudes abs well
so you know you sit it's because of
spooky slenderman's I'm gonna take you
away but hey nice outfit that's
work out there's a reason I'm not called
the buff man I don't put on muscle whoa
yeah well done and then the mom and
sarah and getting last words on the
wrist yeah um and so this this so it's
like this mark was almost like if you
kill whoever has the first the first
symbol in the chain you stop the conduit
it's never explained but just understand
decent yes yeah it's just like you know
so at the end it's like Milo so it's
like they're they're even running all
over town as the Slender Man has been
been haunting them they go to this lodge
or it's like you think that they would
be you think that like they would be
running out of money and and having to
go into progressively shittier hotel
rooms as as the story goes on but now
it's like at the end of the movie that
are this nice like getaway cabin yeah
maybe it's like an Airbnb it's not that
expensive they just what's that with
that app where you can couch surf is it
Airbnb oh maybe yeah um just like I get
a couch in the mountains ten bucks night
so they get to this Lodge and you know
slendy shows up what they realize slendy
she always loved the ethnic name the
slightly shows up just as they as miles
put the map together in his head of oh
when the dad dies it stops the circuit
almost and so I was like as the operator
starting to swoop into the room Milo
grabs a Mylo grabs a noose and he hangs
himself in the room and then it's you
know he falls down off of this newsies
that he's made and then suddenly his
eyes go Blanche white and he becomes
like enthralled or possessed by the
operator and he [ __ ] kills Charlie
and then he tries to kill then tries to
kill Sarah and it seems like he
successfully does and then once he's not
been both out he his eyes go back to
normal you can't tell if he's alive or
dead
it's almost like when when the operator
takes hold of Milo it's like it's
suddenly this it's like this culmination
of um it sounds like this combination of
like a weird relationship he's had with
Charlie and Sarah to begin with like
this ingrown rage towards them because
he was like you wanted to get with you
want to get with Sarah and so yeah
because we're fantasy of her ever since
like they had this little fling or
whatever they have that she regretted
and it's like just this inborn
resentment that's been going on and on
and just this hatred towards Charlie
because you know Sarah and Charlie get
together and it's like and it's almost
like what the operator does in the movie
is like it finds the the point of the
most frustration in you and gets you to
act out on it hmm this letter man is
just a metaphor for voyeuristic
unrequited but yeah so always catches up
with it yeah no yes it does seem to it's
like it worms in the most vulnerable
point and then kind of exploits
everything yeah it makes you wonder I
guess further with the nature of the
sentiment is in the movie yeah very says
it never because first is like the
babadook handled its character really
brilliantly and you without having to
overtly say it you get it he'd fine the
babadook worms its way into you it makes
you act out on the most angry repressed
you know part of yourself that you don't
want to deal with it all seems like this
version of the operator kind of wants to
do the same thing yeah that makes sense
hmm so the slender do the slender Duke
this slender dude it's almost like you
know the babadook was very if the
babadook was about you know motherhood
the frustrations of that and mourning
and grieving and depression it's almost
like this version of the operator in
always watching is about you know that
like you said that voyeuristic thing
that that fantastical need to kind of
like look at other people's lives and
feeling need to transpose yourself and
place yourself into it that kind of
almost narcissism but that insecurities
where I got no faith yeah yeah it's like
almost it's like a representation of
like fear of not having an identity hmm
of like being in fear of being nobody
you know it's like Milo wants to be yeah
and his head he wants to be the most
important person in in Sarah's life but
he knows he's not it's like in that
schism and in that frustration he gets
[ __ ] spook grip maybe Milo was just
two children in a trench coat and that's
why I say twist twist centers no rich or
anything oh yeah cuz like this baby
cousin to really mythos is like you come
to children yeah and is often near white
structure fire yeah yeah it's like
Marvel horn stood out so they found
burned-out buildings for things to take
place and and that was something that's
like from a formalistic standpoint from
an aesthetic standpoint it's like the
Webster's did really cool stuff with
very little like they made you know just
parts in different areas really creepy
and and there was one episode that was
brilliant of the Webster's works like
the camera search you know in the first
person you see someone running through a
house and the way in which they're
running from the house I realize is
impossible yeah yeah yeah well cuz it's
[ __ ] with the physics yes spatial
event conventions it's like he runs into
her closet comes out like downstairs
runs up the same flight of stairs he
just ran up to get to the closet and
then Mike comes out in a bedroom someone
yeah it's a good geometry the house just
stops making sense as each tracking this
person wearing a mask was like you know
directly enthralled by the Slender Man
or somehow affected by them and then he
ends up in this creepy dank dark
basement dank and then when in then I
gasp it
gasps basement and then it's like when
he comes back outside it's nighttime you
know start during the day yeah there's
almost like a [ __ ] you to to wanting to
start this during the day so you don't
get creeped out yeah exactly when that's
I mean that that's the stuff i miss the
note that episode i remember first xix
today's I'd watched a few times because
also I mean the things you can
accomplish with a few quick edits and
just low five you miss it looks looks
great you know that's it's a simple
trick but it's so effective I mean runs
in that closet comes out in the other
side it's a different room yeah you know
it's it's a great little trick in us i
guess it's something that is harder
because the thing that was cool about um
about the web series was that you know
it was all mini DV it was all cheap low
five old cameras and now this movie it's
got that studio gloss on it everything
is and you know their professional news
team so they have access to dsl ours and
GoPros yeah you know high-end cameras
and so it's like what there's more
information available when there's more
you know when there's more of a fine
definition outlook on everything it's
less you know is you're not you're
literally not as in the dark you don't
have any gloss of ignorance well yeah I
mean cuz just just the right amount of
brain on or just take noise you know it
makes the frame busier whereas like an
IHD and stuff like that like everything
is so crisp and clear your meeting room
and so there aren't as many places
you're just not your head is in a
different place where you just don't
expect or or you know there's less that
can be hidden in static or in you know
snow or anything like that so you feel a
little bit safer he loves a big dude
yeah it was just as an aesthetic thing
it's like anything that's a little bit
grimy or a little noisy like it's just a
harder to sort of cut through video
quality will always be pretty here and
that's something that I saw in like I
saw some clips of sinister and I'm
introspection finally see this movie now
because I really like it's like you know
it goes back to super 8 films and they
actually shot those on super from what
I've been told by yeah and those I mean
that's a recurring motif and those are
really unsettling yeah it's like the
less snuff movies yeah it's a
cholesterol information you get the
older the format somehow that instantly
makes everything creepy like you know if
you heard a a creepy song on a CD it's
not the same as Phoebe song on a broken
record that cracks and hawks and skits
yeah exactly i mean you know it's i
don't know exactly what the right word
is but it's just morally alive that way
yeah and then it feels closer to ya
there's my more physical more analog
format see they somehow hit a totally
different they somehow a totally
different nerve been mm-hmm you know HD
stuff you know high fidelity data well
yeah there's there's there's a more sort
of sterile quality of come because anna
even other commonplace you do feel less
in the real world things are so crisp
you know it's like real life is HD but
but not in the same way where it
causative you just have crisp and clear
everything is you you just kind of go
about your day and think about what the
quality at what you're seeing so like
when you have stuff in HD it all kind of
gets that different level sort of
Hollywood II gloss on it yet maybe it's
like the muddiness of older formats of
things like that just one they're less
clear and more and more informations
kind of being withheld from you you feel
less capable you know you feel only
disarmed in a way yeah so you don't have
everything you need don't eyeball the
knowledge or information like survive
mm-hmm it's like an HD you almost have
to do a lot more with restrictive angles
then you then you would I another fun
it's almost like the artifacting and HD
footage is house quickly as the
artifacting low low or five footage yeah
yeah on it it seems like it almost takes
more to conjure that up
so I because everything is it knowledge
including stuff like that word it's like
if something's I'm takers to tracking
your use to even do now and again
distortions in love huh what was weird
to me was at the variant movie that the
credits were all in like impact font and
had like a bunch of JPEG artifacting on
that yeah or not the title is an impact
on then everything else is in like kind
of like a VHS emitting fog I I wish
they've done the total differently yeah
because it makes it look like this was
made by its kids are like a some kind of
wrestling yeah it looks like like the
title card at the bar Melora always
watching subtitle important story yeah
it's like the end sometimes like an
impact font and and it looks like it
belongs on like a video from the
everything is terrible cataloging it it
just kind of feels I don't know it's
just it's just like it just totally felt
it felt like it belonged to a different
movie yeah it felt like it should have
had some kind of chunky rock to not yeah
it's like oh yeah always washes which
has been a motif lately on a lot of not
a lot but a few horn movies I've seen
not me on this movie to do it sort of
the visual denotes that but it's like
poltergeist carry like both of those and
I'm really ill fitting rock and roll
uh-huh where it's just like no now is
not the time for upbeat guitar music
this is Evan descended on silence yeah
that would work but but the the still
when the title showed up I was literally
like that's what was distracted just by
like the way the title looks because it
looks too in-your-face where is the
movie itself I feel like it's more
understanding more subtle yeah weird way
because like everything is really
natural in the movie you despite yeah
it's it's honest I want to put it it
almost feels like it feels like somebody
it feels like the movie was not put out
for life
worcester the most with this property
that we can it was almost like someone
kind of just wanted to do a marbled horn
to me as quick and as fast as possible
but at some point someone else just put
a lot of effort into the people into the
characters yeah its strength like it is
very strange that's a unique I don't
know if I would call it a problem but if
you want to call it a bomb it's like
it's a very unique problem to have for
horror movie yeah yeah because what yeah
like the best stuff about this is none
of what makes it one of this yeah it's
like I mean not that stuff isn't cool to
a degree but like this you know the
horror is relatively mellow like some of
it is kind of paranoid and you know it's
one of those movies where you're sort of
watching people you know deteriorate you
know as the situation gets more and more
hopeless but still it's like it has this
mild meekness to it but just this sort
of makes you wonder like interesting
like well done I'm curious as to why you
need to make this like yeah does the
dude who directed like he's he does a
lot of 8d work and he work on tons of
movies he does he's done a lot of gloom
nasty stuff though he was clearly not
out of his element with low budget and
even found footed you know it's well
assembled but I'm just like it's not in
your face like I was when it finally
ended I was expecting like one more
bigger set well yeah really drive home
the creep and the end up you know
Slenderman eNOS you know because I was
like the where it ends almost feels like
okay finally we've upped the ante a
little bit and now we need one more yeah
and then it's sort of end there which
which makes sense from the stories they
play and there's a there's a sting with
like a the next people to apparently get
like cornered and haunted by the
operator yeah and there I mean I the
married couple at the very end they just
kind of don't feel fitting anymore you
know yeah yeah
you why don't remember if it felt is
naturally yeah its weight yeah it's a
weird film because I don't know what it
would lead to just more of the same kind
of thing like it doesn't it doesn't
really add to the mythology it kind of
just straightens it out you know it kind
of it's like it's like it's like it's
you know it's got more gloss it's got
more shine it's got more toys to play
with is pretty good yeah as a weird
place it's a weird middle ground to
occupy and it's like the things that
does with the mythology are just like to
kind of clean things up and make these I
guess a little more simple and low less
a little less scary yeah second in the
Webster's it's like for instance the
operator is proportions are unnatural
sometimes you know you'll see him enter
a room or you see him go down a hallway
inside cuz he's not the way human being
in shape whereas oh yeah when he doesn't
even answer one color connect one line
of a movie I know right it's just like
what's going on and that's like in the
movie he's just always like he's just
always you know Doug Jones shape to just
always shape like you know then dude in
a suit which is weird to me like he's
def jaam shape but doug jones part of
the appeal of doug jones that you can
shape him to anything to anything yeah
so he's just kind of dude in a suit with
no face which is an unsettling you know
and especially when they put it what if
we put in like outside of a window in a
house like yeah that's creepy because if
somebody's on your porch in there than I
hearing in that's that's not normal
behavior like that's always creepy you
know when he shows up other places it's
eerie like this movie to me was only
ever pretty you like it was never like
glue you know like I remember there was
one click early on in there very early
marble parks episode works like oh this
clip didn't have any audio but I found
it in just to see you guys stopping
around his house with the house is like
plunged into darkness there's no light
on is I coming out of his windows and
his blinds to see what's going on there
you see the operator standing on the
forest with this
turned away from the camera and just
seeing others just doomed the suit on my
porch that's so weird and then head
whips towards the camera directly no
face and then whoever's holding the
camera like bullies from that window and
it's important total silence and like
that silence kind of like helped punch
up the creep factor it's also because
it's further restricting like all you
have to go on then is where the visual
is taking it and the visual is
unreliable enough for details that hang
on to that you're you're so your plane
is so narrow and that makes it scary
because there's not a lot to comfort
yourself with your nerve it's your
you're beholden to wear this dude
besides the point the camera and that's
like the essence of what makes found
footage you think work in theory like
that's you know a big part of what's
scary about phone footage is you have to
be locked on to one point of view and if
that camera turns you don't know what's
going to be there you know so like
that's the furthest conclusion of that
and that that is a big me out early yeah
there there are also things like well
you know there was a mystery element
that I guess was missing in always
watching like rinses in the webseries
there are moments where there's hanging
around a burned-out building or an
abandoned building and they still say
what they think happened there or one of
the official story is of what happened
there but you get the sense enough
weight really knows what happened there
whereas in the movie you did go to a
burned out in house and they see who
burned the house down instantly the fact
that the house is burned down just kind
of like less creepy yeah it's kind of
more frustrating than anything what what
have you do is like okay when it comes
to move it all seems like the most
effective effective MarbleHornets story
at least and maybe maybe Slenderman
sword down like that has to be about
people who don't have a ton to do with
their times like yeah we're making this
short film but are we were making this
film you know and then we know stop for
whatever reason and like these please
kit like these kids like these young
people
well you had the time to devote slight
on-the-go research this today like you
know even if they have jobs we're like
you know these these people work for the
news like clearly work would take up a
big amount of their day and they have
lives going on like they it's even in a
more populated area where it's like
there's less to do there yeah you can
kind of chase the story and get obsessed
with it but I always feel like they're
there are more opportunities to sneak
around to get into some really cool like
for situations fit with what they'll
have sickest yeah it's also in the web
series you know there were kids who they
didn't have as much to do so they could
go poking around so they didn't have the
resources to find out what things were
like there was that that whole thing in
Marble Hornets just like this weird lead
rusty structure in the middle of some
park somewhere that no yeah knew what it
was and you know props to those kids
from finding that thing cuz it was
terrifying it was really creepy nothing
super spooky happened it was just like
this big weird tower of rusted metal in
the middle of a part and someone had a
guess of like I was like an old climbing
wall or something but it just felt like
such a weird artifact that didn't really
belong there it's not a front I wonder I
wish I can just sit in and listen to
them talk about their locations yeah
because there's a lot of great location
stuff and they just found it in their
neighborhood the surrounding towns
around them well that's what I wonder is
like I wonder if some of this stuff is
like places they've driven past a
million times growing up or whatever
that there are no I would use that with
you that you know and what they had
these like strikeout in fine even yeah
and how much how many things were
inspired by oh that's a cool structure
let's use it persons like we need a
structure like where we find it yeah you
know it's like say in the in the
Webster's this red tower that they don't
explain what it is or what it was there
for and what the connection is to the
operator whereas say in the movie they
find a bunker in the bunker was set up
by the dad who was scared about the
operator so he set up a bunker so it's
like
the instant things are batiks it's weird
it's like the thing about the web series
was that things weren't that spelled out
and drawn out or explain but there were
hints enough that made them feel really
creepy whereas the movie version of the
operator has he feels like he has less
mystery and lets mythology around it
yeah and even less is into that or
explain it's almost like the web series
version of the operator was come from a
richer more fuller mythology than the
movie version that maybe just because
they were kind of doing a kind of doing
a lost on on the web series work just
like you know they were thinking of cool
stuff for the operator to do and be
connected to on the fly hmm whereas the
movie had to kind of plan things out in
the long the waywards you no doubt what
kind of fly by the cedar pants like hey
let's do this thing cuz they'll be cool
TV yeah and so that hey let's do this
thing because it would be cool and
spooky that suddenly adds to the printer
mythology that's being implied you like
bronze about well there there you can
get really good things out of that if
you know how to use them right because
sometimes you're just getting something
that seems cool it's like you're not
thinking too hard about it yeah it's
like you can stumble across something
and then figure out how to work it in
like that that's a workable precess and
like you said like the two of the art
stuff was like that was such a cool
extra voice in the web series and we sad
to not have that or anything close to
that in in the movie well because and
and that's the thing that we're like
doing it on youtube or just the internet
gives it something it's like that's a
very something very specific to that
medium words that you can do that then
now you've established two different
channels of storytelling if you want to
call it that in the same you don't forum
but it's like a movie you can't exactly
do that because you have to stop the
movie and find a supplementary piece of
material yeah we create two different
YouTube channels like that and throw
these different things on them and make
them link up you know you've created
an error mr. in it and it makes it all
the more immersive because you still
have to go on the internet and look for
these then you know or notice that
they're there so for those who aren't
words like you know in the original web
services this other so there was the
marble hard youtube channel where it was
quote unquote J you know going through
the old footage and like finding clues
and explaining things to you know the
viewer as to what he was seeing and then
there was this other YouTube channel to
the arc that was by arc God who knows
who it seemed to be this person i was
wearing dislike doll mask that had been
painted on yeah um that had like footage
of j in certain places and like the
missing pieces of footage that that Jay
had and it was just like clearly this
guy knew a lot but he was like he spoke
really cryptically and and everything
that I've had this kind of moved
foreboding about it and the language
there was a lot of use of like you know
holds archival footage and archival
music that was being reversed and edited
and heavily chopped and screwed in these
really creepy ways so it was like almost
like someone was trying to someone it
was almost like a message from the world
that the operator was coming out but
like this message was because of
whatever the operator was doing it was
like so distorted in the data and so
destroyed in the video but it was also
distorted like the psychology it was
almost like whoever was sending these
messages was kind of [ __ ] in the head
because of how deep into this you got ya
what and that like they're the images
themselves and the videos are unsettling
and then just the fact that you have
those puzzle pieces of like here's that
missing footage and or like here is you
know a reverse shot from across the room
where someone is clearly in there with
you while you're asleep or whatever like
it it takes that main narrative and
makes it so the interesting here's you
somewhere sometime you don't remember at
all yeah it's like then it gives this
very intrusive but it just has a very
intrusive quality that makes the main
story if you want to call it that much
more paranoid and
sense that like there is no safety even
when sleeping you know because you know
so this whatever this entity is pretty
much has access to you and your [ __ ] all
the time yeah and you don't have any
control over that yeah or at least like
intermittently has exclusive access to
you yeah you know as you're slowly going
out of your width yeah so and you know
it's just having that extra having that
extra part of it just kinda it felt so I
mean it would turn the return always
watching from I could not even a film
into like a two-hour film probably but
it's like it felt like it needed I would
have loved to have had something like
that in the movie yeah and I have a hard
time greater feeling of vulnerability is
that great week factor I'm hard time
figuring out how you would introduce
that in a truly effective way or like in
a way that would be as effective as it
was just watching these things unfold
online because to like there's something
that adds to it there's almost like a
cheek waters where it's like you have
these episodes then you have to wait
time to see where the story like there's
there's greater it feels all more real
because there's greater allowance for
passage of time and stuff like that and
I'm trying to figure out how the movie
could have slipped these other things in
in a way that would still feel
disconcerting and not like a movie is
doing that you know yeah it's like it's
hard to divorce yourself from them from
one film as its own entity you know it's
like if somebody slipped footage in
there so you could just randomly edit in
a very strange piece of footage and then
the next thing half characters be
checking it out or you know even talking
the camera like we found this in our
footage I don't know yeah but you know
the part of the problem of the
found-footage movie is the concede the
sort of unspoken can see that you tend
to forget about that well if we want to
believe this is kind of real somebody
must have compiled this footage and
together you know so you can't almost
have I guess you could it would just be
hard to sell the whole leg this one is
randomly got in here yeah you know so
it's a problematic I don't think it's
impossible but it would require a lot of
figure
I'm or anything could have done in such
a calm photos that they had done um the
movie I saw like a monkey morning huh as
a poor now yeah we actually got to take
a break folks but we will be right back
take a por nombre por break